瑞姐，
提高沟通能力，
推荐一本书啊，
我不建议通过看书去提高沟通能力，
因为我觉得这个是纸上得来，
终觉起来，
你你要说提高沟通能力的话，
就是你靠嘴练，
你不行的话，
我有一个想法，
姐妹们啊，
我打算专门开一个号来拍我学习英语的过程，
就我每天花一分钟的时间去把我今天学习到的一段演讲，
我脱口我就讲出来，
每天记录自己一分钟的英语演讲，
大家有没有兴趣看，
有没有兴趣看，
因为我现在年纪越来越那个什么嘛，
小孩子他可能也要开始启蒙学英语了，
我是希望以后我跟我的孩子可以是用英语交流，
用粤语交流，
用中文交流，
我希望他的世界里面就这三门语言，
他都能够运用的非常的熟练，
可以随时切换那种的，
我打算这么学习，
我以前不是喜欢看那个绝望的主妇嘛，
我打算绝望的主妇的台词，
比如那个主角Mary alens,
他的台词很多我都很喜欢，
因为他的台词很多都是洞察人性啊，
还有一些自己的人生感悟啊什么什么的，
我就专门去把他的台词扒下来，
一分钟一分钟的台词，
然后我把他的那个影片放在下面，
或者说把他的影片放在上面，
他把的头放在下面，
我就念他的台词，
对他的口型，
就这样去学习。
回头我把我这个想法给我的剪辑师剑心歌跟他说一下，
我让他给我剪辑出这种效果来，
就是每天一分钟，
每天一分钟的。
点一点的去练我自己的英语表达，
那你其实同样的道理，
如果你想要练你的中文表达的话，
你也就可以运用跟我一样的方法呀，
你喜欢的那些电视剧的台词，
举个例子，
肖景瑞的台词在琅琊榜的台词对不对？
肖景瑞在琅琊榜和梅长苏的那个对白，
你就用这个一分钟的时间，
你去把它背下来，
你去练你自己的表达，
比你们看书真的要强一万倍，
你要相信王菲姐的这个方法，
比你去说我看一本书，
我提高我的表达要强一万倍，
你信吗？
每天用一段时间，
不干别的，
跟着台词，
念台词，
背台词，
然后把你融入到台词里面的那个角色的情境当中，
有感情的把这个台词说出来，
你如果说你能坚持30天的话，
你的表达肯定大不一样，
哎，
有时候激动人心，
好，
你要确实清，
我自己坚持不了，
你也坚持啊，
每天一分钟台词啊，
发作品啊，
语言就是一个人的世界，
语言就是一个人的名片，
语言就是一个人的风水，
语言就是一个人的气质。
天呐，
我简直是一个P位大师，
我以后都想象，
我就想象不到我的孩子会被我PUN成什么样子啊。
刚刚有人说鸿飞没问题的，
你是高材生，
所以没有问题，
其实我觉得这事儿的话真的看决心，
因为我那天看到过一个视频啊，
一个女生，
她一儿一女在家全职带孩子，
她老公是一个程序员，
说每个月的工资都是交给她的，
然后。
为什么她作为一个小学生，
她在家带两个孩子，
她的老公把工资都交给她，
同时还对她那么尊敬吗？
她虽然是一个小学生，
但是她在这些年的过程中从来都没有停止学习，
如果她在带孩子的过程当中，
他也没有停止学习，
他带孩子的过程当中，
他学了一个营养师证，
那么带孩子的过程当中，
他学了那种美食啊，
搭配啊什么的，
这次也考了个厨师证之类的，
然后还学了儿童心理学，
同时她还学了拍照，
她还学了剪视频，
她还学了做自媒体，
大概就是这意思吧，
反正我看到那个视频的话啊，
我真的挺感动的，
我我想着说，
我我在直播间一定要讲给大家听，
虽然她是小学毕业，
虽然她跟她的老公之间的学历差距非常大，
她老公是至少是本科打底嘛，
但她老公对她非常尊重，
每个月的钱都交给她，
我明白这个意思吗？
我讲这段话其实想表达的意思就是，
你不要觉得说龙飞姐，
因为你是高材生，
所以你学什么东西都容易，
不是是你自己有没有这个决心干这个事儿，
你自己有没有因为表达能力不行错失过很多机会，
你有没有因为表达能力差，
连跟别人表白的时候都占不到先机，
有没有因为表达能力差，
你在冤枉的时候你就没法替自己辩解，
如果你经历过这些事情的话，
你一定有动力把表达能力练上去，
我又对你们进行了一场非常深刻的PUA。
要么说认识王菲姐简。
简直就是入股不亏啊，
还有刚刚有个姐妹说，
因为你表达能力不行，
你连吵架你都吵不赢，
就是菲姐佩服自己的一天，
果然是了解我，
记得点赞关注哦。